thanks for being out here tonight my
name is Jonathan and I'm super excited
to talk about something that's really
near and dear to my heart and that is
side hustles so for the next 15 minutes
I'm gonna convince you why you should
have a side hustle and then want to talk
about how to get started so first let's
define what is a main hustle to me a
main hustle is the thing that you do
Monday to Friday probably 9:00 to 5:00
9:00 to 6:00 something like that it's
the thing that pays most if not all of
your bills and you probably have a team
that you work with at your main hustle
so then what's a side hustle well simply
it's the thing that you do in the
mornings before you go to work in the
evenings after work or on the weekends a
side hustle truth be told you're
probably not making any money from it
maybe you're starting to and then the
other part of a side hustle is that most
likely you're working on it by yourself
you might have one or two other people
but in contrast to the main hustle it's
a small team the one big element I want
to highlight or stress related to side
hustles is it has a huge element of
creation and not consumption so that
means if you are binge watching a series
on Netflix that's probably not a side
hustle but but but if you are intending
to write a blog about that that some day
you might then try to monetize that
might be a side hustle what's really
really fascinating is when you put these
two together I found in my experience
that when you have a side hustle your
main hustle gets better and when your
main hustle gets better your side hustle
gets better so they just keep on
cascading on one another and that's what
I really want to talk to you about
tonight it's this middle zone that I
call the magic spot so let's do it first
let me tell you a little bit about my
main hustle and my side hustle to really
set the stage my main hustle is compass
compass if you don't know is a real
estate tech startup based out in New
York City as of last fall we crossed
over the 1 billion dollar valuation so
in
startup land that's pretty cool because
thank you well don't thank me thank our
team but it's really cool because we are
in a hyper growth state of the company
and what makes it even more fascinating
is that I'm a product manager a compass
so not only am i riding this rocket ship
but I'm actively helping to shape our
product set and so what excuse me what I
do is I help empower our compass agents
who then use our tools to work with
their buyers and sellers and guide them
through a really complex and large
financial decision let me give you an
example of a tool that we built and
launched
it's called collections and this tool is
meant to be used between agents their
buyers and co purchasers during the home
search process so on the surface what
you see here is a Pinterest style board
all the people involved in the home
search process can contribute and say
hey I think this is a good potential
home but it doesn't stop there because
when homes get added there's a lot of
conversation so it's a big collaboration
element that we built into the tool
people are gonna ask questions can i
renovate the kitchen what's the view
from the bedroom
how many how long does it take me to get
to the subway and your agent is really
there to facilitate and guide that
process through and then finally there's
a big element of organization for every
hundred homes that you decide that could
be a potential fit 99 of them aren't
going to work for one reason or another
so there's a way to organize homes that
you are interested in not interested in
but then keep the conversation really
flowing now what's really wonderful
about this is when you look at it
there's really nothing revolutionary
about this when you buy a home
regardless of when you bought it maybe
in the 80 70 60 you did the same process
the problem was all of it happened over
diverging trails and there was really no
organization so after you talked about a
home three weeks later it kind of just
faded into the ether and that limits
decision-making when you don't see what
you're looking at and you can't compare
to the other tools or other listings
sorry so collections that's what we
built it's our flagship product and it's
getting a lot of positive adoption from
our agent community as well as their
buyers
now let me tell you about my side hustle
it's called tribe of five and we're in
the business of accountability we help
you start off and follow through with
good habits that make you more healthy
wealthy and wise so what I mean is when
you as an individual commit to work on a
goal through tribe of five we take care
of all the nasty work and pair you up
with four other people who are also
working on the same goal and through the
format of a 30-day challenge every
single day you commit to a small daily
action and you hold each other
accountable and believe it or not in a
period of 30 days you will make
significant progress and don't worry
I'll talk about this more but I wanted
to first set the stage between compass
and tribe of five so let's really talk
about why you should have a side hustle
and I'm going to share three reasons why
you should have a side hustle but by no
means is it really only these three
there are so many benefits I think of
having a side hustle but I'll talk about
three the first of which is that I think
a side hustle helps you connect the dots
and let me share a story with you about
how my side hustle tribe of five really
helped me improve my main hustle at
Compass now I wish that as a product
manager I could keep track of all the
basics and foundations of product
management and I wish that at the right
time I can always pull out the right
tool to solve the right problem but
realistically that doesn't happen well
it doesn't always happen but a few I
believe that it with a side hustle
you're more likely to do that one of the
basics that I was able to renew recently
was the concept around forgetting what
you think is the right thing to do and
always going out and testing with your
users so with tribe of five we were
building out a construct for a morning
routine 30-day challenge and we got
stuck thinking about whether you have a
fixed check-in time or whether you have
floating check-in time and maybe because
it was a low-pressure environment we
knew we didn't know the answer so we
went out and talked to a lot of users
and what we found was we had a lot of
blind spots it wasn't just that there
was a whole spectrum of things that we
needed to consider
and without talking to those users who
knows what we would have come up with
now a compass I recently found myself in
a conversation I'm not proud to be in I
got into a conversation with my engineer
where we went into I feel this is better
for the user I feel this is better for
the user and I would like to believe
that at that moment I would have pulled
out the phrase hey we got to go test
this but because I was working on tribe
of five because it was top of mind it
popped out it just I just blurted it and
we went and we tested we validated and
we built the right product because we
talked to our users so I think it's
really important that as a product
manager it's a current product manager
you're always renewing the basics of
product management the school the skills
the theories and then being able to
apply it now for all the prospective
product managers out there your role is
your job is to try to stand out and I
believe that a side hustle is one of the
best ways to stand out because there are
really two different types of product
managers out there there are textbook
product managers and then there are
battle tested product managers a
textbook product manager knows what to
do they've read the books they
understand the concepts they probably
just haven't had it enough opportunity
to really apply it and really go through
it on the other end there's a
battle-tested p.m. they have that's all
that's the difference they've gotten
banged around they've learned what works
and how to apply different situations to
different scenarios now if you're a
prospective PM you're gonna say well I
haven't had the opportunity to do that
stuff but if you work on a side hustle
because you're working on it by yourself
you get to make decisions you get to try
things out you get to fail in a low
pressure environment and that becomes a
talking point that you bring with you
and that you share and you it's in my
opinion how you become a battle-tested
p.m. so that's a way to help you connect
the dots the second reason why I think
you should have a side hustle is that
you're going to get inspired now as a
product manager we're always looking out
into the world and trying to get
inspiration from different products that
we can then bring into our own and I
believe that with a side hustle it helps
you just widen the lens so I want to
talk about it
story of how my main hustle helped me
improve my side hustle so after the
launch of collections we partnered up
with a vendor called pendo I know they
got a couple pendo guys sitting back
there so hey what's up
now pen dough was really valuable for
our collections launch and post
collections launch because pendo allows
you to add in app guides tooltips and
walkthroughs all without the help of
your engineers that means that for me I
could have my engineers working on more
pressing things well I well I could go
in and add some of the first-time user
experience stuff and this is so powerful
because when you build a product yes you
do think about the first-time user
experience but a lot of the time that
you're spending is thinking about deep
into the engagement how you keep them
going all of that other stuff now
because I had to go back and add these
tool guides it made me really think
through the first time experience for
collections and that in turn has helped
me really think much deeper about tribe
of five it's a semi complex product
you're getting in there you're
interacting with other people there's
something you need to do I don't want to
have people chance it and just flub
their way through the product I want to
guide them I want to help steer them
into the right direction and pendo is
really a forcing function through my
main hustle that's improved what I do
with tribe of five now the third reason
why I think you should have a side
hustle is that you are just gonna meet
more people have you ever had a
conversation where you leave feeling man
that was so great we went really deep we
really had an engaging conversation and
then you have others where you can
barely break through the surface like
you can't get past names and what do you
do and it's just kind of pulling teeth
well I think that you need a reason to
go meet people and with a side hustle it
provides that reason without it like if
you just stuck me like like someone at a
grocery store I don't really have much
reason to talk to them so maybe we'll
get past it but because I'm working on a
side how so I'm just naturally
interested in a lot of things that are
going on I'm interested in what other
people are doing and that has this
virtuous effect where I learn more so as
an example I met this designer
and he loves aerial photography like
flying drones and all that stuff and it
doesn't have anything directly to do
with tribe of five except that in the
near future potentially there could be a
30 day challenge around photography and
who better to talk to now than this
designer that I've met well it kind of
helped connect the dots and help me to
meet them
and there's another story I met a girl
who is doing a makeup brush company some
sort of motorized brush head I don't
really know what it's all about
and on the surface it seems so different
than what I'm doing but believe it or
not we're actually very much the same
we're starting out we don't have a brand
presence we're trying to acquire new
users and we don't have a marketing
budget so we got to very quickly talk
about strategies whether it's through
Facebook groups how to use reddit for
acquisition and it was just a
fascinating conversation so I think with
the side hustle you're just gonna meet
more people so hopefully I've done a
decent enough job getting peaking your
interests into why you should have a
side hustle and so let's take a few
minutes to talk about how to get started
and really there's two ways to get
started you can either work on it alone
and working on alone it's great because
it's easy and you could really start
whenever you want and let me give you
the recipe if you do want to work under
the loan it's nothing revolutionary you
have to commit to do something daily
especially when you're starting out I'm
not talking about like hours and hours
but something like as simple as five ten
twenty minutes a day and you have to
commit to do it consistently at least in
the beginning to build that habit to
kind of get used to it
now what I've seen through my experience
is that a lot of people try it out and
they fall off they get stuck and kind of
like this picture here he's kind of
going into the fog and he's not really
sure what's next when you're working on
something by yourself you're gonna have
questions you're gonna get stuck at some
points in time and without people there
to kind of cheer you on inspire you help
you it's easy to say well I'll just do
it later and then that means that you
end up dropping off so you could do it
alone and here's the recipe but what I
think is a better strategy
is to work on it together and I don't
mean like Foreman ID and all like five
people go off and like only solve that
idea but what if like you could find for
other people who are also interested in
a side hustle and all you did was keep
each other accountable because I believe
that with a healthy dose of
accountability these people in this
small group here are much more likely to
make it up this proverbial mountain if
you will and the reason that happens is
if you're this guy with the green
backpack and you're having one of those
days or you just don't want to do it you
also don't want to let your group down
five people's personal off where you
know everyone on a first-name basis so
on those days where you don't want to do
it guess what you're gonna do it and for
the people who are feeling really
inspired they're gonna be helping out
and they're gonna be offering tips and
together you're gonna work on it and
really accomplish much more than you
could alone but you really I think with
accountability you need a common goal if
for instance these people are all trying
to climb the mountain that's a common
goal but if this guy wanted to go
swimming and this guy wanted to to learn
to draw and someone else is trying to do
calculus yeah maybe you could keep each
other accountable but you missed that
like deeper layer of really conversation
and so really that's the secret behind
tribe of five and that's why I think
that tribe of five is the best way to
get started so if you believe that
accountability could help you out and
you are wanting to work on something
individually it's the same as before you
have to commit to do something daily and
you have to be consistent about it but
with tribe of five we layer on the
accountability we help you find those
accountability buddies and we show you a
simple blueprint for 30 days to show you
really how to get started and really to
stick with it so with that said I'm
starting to tribes upcoming if you're a
person who is looking for a side hustle
you don't have an idea yet then you
should join this tribe we're going to
take five people and every single day
we're going to identify three potential
ideas and we're gonna share it with a
tribe we're going to bounce ideas and
you're gonna collect so many good ideas
and at the end we're gonna call it down
to one or two good things that you're
gonna want to pursue so if this sounds
like something that you're interested in
you
tell me better a tribe v dot me and put
something in the subject related to you
want to find a side hustle now let's say
you already have a side hustle you have
something but you're just not
consistently working on it well this is
for you then because that's what you
need to do you need to make some
progress on your side hustle and the way
that we're gonna do it is injecting
accountability so commit to do 30
minutes for the next 30 days and join me
and join four other people here tonight
again email me something about working
on your side hustle you're going to
bounce ideas share information at the
end of 30 days I guarantee you you're
gonna make so much progress so with that
said I want to thank you and if you're
looking to buy a house check out compass
and if you're looking for accountability
check out tribe of five
[Applause]